♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT’S JOE BIDEN’S FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE AND WE KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
CNN CAN FINALLY TAKE THAT COVID
DEATH STICKER OFF HIS SCREEN.
THERE’S NO REASON FOR IT NOW.
IT’S NOT LIKE YOU CAN BLAME
JOE BIDEN WITH FOR SOME CHINESE
THAT ESCAPES FROM A LAB IN WUHAN
WUHAN.
COVID DEATHS?
SETTLE DOWN, AMERICA.
IT’S JUST A BAD FLU SEASON.
SO BITE AND APPARENTLY AGREES.
THEY WERE SEEN WITHOUT MASKS.
BUT IT’S NOT A BIG DEAL.
HE WAS CELEBRATING AN HISTORIC
DAY IN OUR COUNTRY.
HE HAD BIGGER THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT.
OKAY, MAKES SENSE.
BY THE WAY, WHAT ARE THOSE
BIGGER THINGS THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
WORRIED ABOUT?
WELL, SINCE IT HAPPENS TO BE HIS
DAY ON THE JOB, WE CAN ACTUALLY
ANSWER THAT QUESTION WITH SOME
SPECIFICITY.
YOU CAN TELL THAT WHAT PEOPLE
CARE MOST ABOUT IS AT THE TOP OF
THEIR TO-DO LIST AND WHAT ARE AT
THE TOP OF JOE BIDEN’S TO-DO
LIST ARE TO CALL THINGS.
OPENING THE BORDERS AND CRUSHING
OUR COUNTRY’S ECONOMIC SECTOR.
THAT’S WHAT HE’S DOING.
FIRST HE SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER REVOKING THE PROMISE OF A
KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
NO MATTER HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
FOSSIL FUEL, WHETHER YOU DRIVE A
CAR OR USE THE HOSPITAL, YOU MAY
BE DUMB I WANT TO THINK ABOUT
HOW YOU USE FOSSIL
FUELS.
THERE IS NO GETTING AROUND
ECONOMIC EFFECT OF THIS
DECISION.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS DON’T HAVE
JOBS RIGHT NOW.
JOE BIDEN HAS PUT ANOTHER 11,000
PEOPLE OUT OF WORK IN THIS
COUNTRY JUST LIKE THAT.
BUT HE WASN’T DONE.
BIDEN ALSO INSTRUCTED HIS
SECURITY TO A HALT DEPORTATION
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WHEN WE SAY ILLEGAL ALIENS, BY
THE WAY, PRETTY SURE WE WON’T BE
ALLOWED TO SAY ILLEGAL ALIENS
BECAUSE IT’S HATE SPEECH.
BUT WHEN WE SAY ILLEGAL ALIENS,
WE MEAN MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS, NOT JUST THE COUNTLESS
UNDOCUMENTED.
THIS DOESN’T APPLY SIMPLY TO
THEM.
BIDEN’S ORDER ALSO INCLUDES
CRIMINALS.
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE DANGEROUS
TO YOU AND ME.
SO THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
YOU CAN BREAK OUR LAWS.
YOU CAN COMMIT VIOLENT FELONIES
ONCE YOU ARRIVE.
JOE BIDEN WILL REWARD YOU WITH
AMNESTY.
THAT GOES TO SHOW HOW MUCH HE
MEANS IT AND HE WILL DO IT ON
HIS VERY FIRST DAY AS A
PRESIDENT.
SO WHY AFTER SEEING THAT
STATEMENT EVERY PERSON IN THE PO
THE WORLD WHEN IT SNEAK INTO
AMERICA?
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF EXPLAINED THAT
WHEN HE FIRST STARTED RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
>> WE CAN AFFORD TO TAKE IN A
HEARTBEAT ANOTHER 2 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT A COUNTRY OF
330 MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT ABSORB
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DESPERATE NEED
AND WHO ARE JUSTIFIABLY FLEEING
OPPRESSION IS ABSOLUTELY
BIZARRE.
ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
I WOULD ALSO MOVE TO INCREASE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS
ABLE TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES UNITED STATES.
THE ONE WE CAN AFFORD TO TAKE
ANOTHER 2 MILLION PEOPLE IN A
HEARTBEAT, EXPLAINED JOE BIDEN.
ARE WE GETTING A LOT RICHER?
HAVE YOU DONE THE MATH ON THAT,
MR. PRESIDENT?
HOW EXACTLY DID YOU CALCULATE
THOSE NUMBERS?
CAN WE SEE THEM?
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN’T SEE THOSE
NUMBERS.
JOE BIDEN IS ALL CLOSER TO A
RELIGIOUS LEADER THAN AN
ACCOUNTANT.
THAT’S WHY HE UNVEILED A BUST OF
CESAR CHAVEZ.
ARE EASILY IMPRESSED FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA WERE NEEDLESS TO SAY
EASILY IMPRESSED.
THEY SAW THE GESTURE OF RACIAL
SOLIDARITY OR SOMETHING.
HE SIGNALS A NEW ERA FOR
LATINOS, ACTIVISTS HOPE READ A
TOTALLY REAL HEADLINE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
IT’S ALL PRETTY HILARIOUS IF YOU
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT CESAR
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ, THE MAN.
THE REAL CESAR CHAVEZ
PASSIONATELY HATED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
HE SAID SO ALL THE TIME.
HE NEVER STOP SAYING IT.
IMMIGRATION LOWERS THE WAGES OF
AMERICAN WORKERS.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF IT, OF
COURSE.
CESAR CHAVEZ WASN’T WELL
EDUCATED BUT HE WAS NOT STUPID.
HE UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
HE WAS ENRAGED BY THE EFFORTS TO
OPEN OUR BORDER WITH MEXICO.
HE KNEW IT WAS A CORPORATE SCAM
POSING AS HUMAN RIGHTS.
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT REFUSED TO
CLOSE THE BORDER, CESAR CHAVEZ’S
MEN DID IT THEMSELVES.
THEY FORMED WHAT THEY CALLED A
HUMAN --
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN DESERT AND
BRUTALLY ASSAULTED MEXICAN
NATIONALS TRYING TO COME NORTH
FROM WORK.
THAT HAPPENED FOR REAL.
THAT’S THE GUY JOE BIDEN JUST
TOLD US HE REVERES.
NO ONE ONE IN CENTRAL AMERICA
BELIEVES THAT, BELIEVES
JOE BIDEN HAS ANY IDEA WHO CESAR
CHAVEZ IS.
ALL THEY KNOW IS THAT AMNESTY
HAS BEEN ANNOUNCED SO OF COURSE
THEY ARE COMING.
WHY WOULDN’T THEY?
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT FOR YOUR
PEOPLE?
>> WHAT I WANT FOR MY PEOPLE, I
JUST WANT PATIENTS THAT WE CAN
GET TO THE U.S. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A NEW PRESIDENT, BIDEN.
HE’S GOING TO GIVE US 100 DAYS
TO GET TO THE U.S. AND GIVE US A
PAPER SO WE CAN GET A BETTER
LIFE FOR OUR KIDS AND FAMILY.
>> Tucker: 100 DAYS.
THAT’S BETTER THAN MOST
AMERICANS.
HE IS GOING TO HELP ALL OF THEM.
AND THEY ARE RIGHT.
ALL OF US INCLUDES PEOPLE
LIKE --
HE WAS ARRESTED IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR SEXUALLY ASSAULTING A MINOR.
SO DOES JUAN HERNANDEZ RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ.
HE IS A SELF-DESCRIBED GANG
MEMBER WITH FELONIES.
HE HAS BEEN ORDERED REMOVED FROM
THIS COUNTRY 5 SEPARATE TIMES
AND HE IS STAYING.
SO IS ANOTHER CONVICTED GANG
MEMBER.
ALSO LOUISE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ.
HE WAS ALSO CONVICTED TO
MANSLAUGHTER ALONG WITH ARM
DRIVER A.
WHEN JOE BIDEN TELLS YOU THE
REAL THREAT FROM OUR COUNTRY
COMES FROM WITHIN, THESE ARE NOT
THE REAL PEOPLE HE’S TALKING
ABOUT.
HE CERTAINLY NOT TALKING ABOUT
GARCIA.
LIKE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA, GARCIA IS LIVING IN
THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
HE HAS BEEN ARRESTED MULTIPLE
TIMES FOR VIOLENT CRIMES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ALLOWED HIM TO STAY IN ORDER TO
NOT SEEM RACIST.
THEN FINALLY, INEVITABLY IN
NOVEMBER, THIS HAPPENS.
>> HAD SAN JOSE TRANSFORMED INTO
A HORRIFIC CRIME SCENE IN WHAT
THE MIRROR SAYS WAS A
PREVENTABLE TRAGEDY.
>> MULTIPLE SYSTEM TRAGEDIES LED
TO THIS MOMENT.
>> POLICE SAY FERNANDO LOPEZ USE
THE KNIFE TO STAB FIVE PEOPLE AT
BAPTIST CHURCH WHICH WAS SERVING
AS A HOMELESS SHELTER.
TO QUOTE PEOPLE, A MAN AND A
WOMAN WERE KILLED.
OFFICIALS SAY HE SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN OUT ON THE STREETS.
>> Tucker: IT WAS A FAILURE OF
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS.
NO, IT WASN’T.
OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
WE JUST DON’T USE IT.
IT WAS A FAILURE OF WILL.
IT WAS OUR COUNTRY PERVERTED BY
BAD IDEAS.
DESTRUCTIVE SUICIDAL IDEAS.
IMMIGRATION LAWS EXIST TO KEEP
THINGS LIKE THE THING YOU JUST
SAW FROM HAPPENING.
IN A TYPICAL 100 A PERIOD LIKE
LAST YEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, FEDERAL
I.C.E. AGENTS REMOVE 46,800
IMMIGRANTS OF PENDING
CONVICTIONS FOR CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
THAT’S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
46,000.
THEY SOUND LIKE THEY ARE TRYING
TO OPERATE A RESTAURANT IN
NEW JERSEY.
THEY ARE NOT CRIMINALS.
THEY ARE CIVIL RIGHTS HEROES.
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN, THEY
ARE DEFINITELY NOT ALIENS.
AND THAT’S ANOTHER THING WE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS WEEK.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DEMANDS
THAT FEDERAL AGENTS REFERRED TO
ILLEGAL ALIENS AS NONCITIZENS.
IT’S WAY LESS RACIST, SO IS
BETTER.
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO HE KEPT
FORGETTING AND WAS STILL USING
THE WRONG TERM.
>> THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS YOU
CANNOT REPORT IN AN UNDOCUMENTED
ALIEN, AN UNDOCUMENTED PERSON
FOR.
>> Tucker: UNDOCUMENTED ALIEN.
OH, SORRY, UNDOCUMENTED PERSON.
THAT WAS CLOSE.
AT 78, HE NARROWLY AVOIDED A
MOMENT OF WHITE SUPREMACY ON
TELEVISION.
REST ASSURED, JOE BIDEN IS
CAREFUL WITH HIS LANGUAGE.
HE KNOWS IN THE NAME OF UNITY,
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
USE CERTAIN WORDS OR HAVE
CERTAIN THOUGHTS.
EVERYONE MUST THINK EXACTLY THE
SAME THING ALL THE TIME.
NOW, IF THAT SEEMS LIKE
MANDATORY CONFORMITY TO YOU, NO,
IT’S UNITY.
AND THAT’S WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WEBSITE, YOU CAN
NOW SELECT PRONOUNS AS YOU
FILL OUT THE CONTACT FORM.
BIGOTRY HAS MET ITS DEFEAT ON
THE WEBSITE.
WE DO HAVE ONE NAGGING QUESTION
THOUGH.
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE POINT OF
THESE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS?
WELL, ANY OF THE CHANGES SOME OF
THESE THINGS JOE BIDEN HAS
ENACTED ON HIS VERY FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE ACTUALLY HELP ANY LIVING
AMERICAN?
WE ARE PRETTY SURE THAT THE
PRONOUN THING WILL ALLUDE TO ANY
UNHAPPY PEOPLE.
TALK ABOUT A WAR ON NATURE.
THAT’S VERY EXCITING.
CONGRATS TO THEM.
BUT WHAT ABOUT EVERYONE ELSE?
HOW DOES AMNESTY AND THE WAVES
OF MASS ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION THAT
WILL INEVITABLY FOLLOW MAKE THIS
A BETTER MORE UNITED COUNTRY?
I’M NOT SUPPOSED TO ASK THAT
QUESTION BUT IT’S TOTALLY FAIR
FOR THE REST OF US WHO LIVE
HERE.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
HOW DOES THIS MAKE OUR COUNTRY
BETTER AND MORE UNITED?
ANYONE WHO TRIES TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION, NOT THAT ANYONE HAS SO
FAR, BUT ANYONE WHO DOES SHOULD
FIRST HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THE STATE WITH THE
MOST ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION SO FAR.
HOW IN THE COURSE OF A SINGLE
GENERATION DID THE BEST STATE
BECOME THE WORST STATE?
HOW DID A STATE THAT PEOPLE
DESPERATELY WANT TO MOVE TO
BECOME THE PLACE WHERE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ARE FLEEING?
HONESTLY, WHAT IS THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION?
IT DID COME UP.
HERE IS HOW A WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY RESPONDED TO IT.
>> IMMIGRATION, WE CONSIDER AS
PART OF RACIAL EQUITY AND PART
OF WHICH IS A BROAD ISSUE.
BUT THAT’S HOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
SPOKEN ABOUT THAT CRISIS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND
CLEARLY IT IS AN ENORMOUS
PRIORITY TO HIM.
>> Tucker: SO THERE YOU GO.
THAT’S THE ANSWER, I GUESS.
THE BIDENS ADMINISTRATION PLAN
IS NOT DESIGNED TO IMPROVE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT IS NOT INTENDED TO MAKE
AMERICA HAPPIER OR RICHER, OR
MORE SECURE, OR MORE UNITED.
NOW YOU MIGHT THINK THOSE WOULD
BE THE AIMS OF EVERY GOVERNMENT
POLICY ALWAYS.
BUT NO.
NOT IN THIS CASE.
THE POINT OF JOE BIDEN’S
IMMIGRATION PLAN IS "RACIAL
EQUITY.
NOW, WE’VE GOT TO BE COMPLETELY
HONEST WITH YOU AND SAY THAT WE
ARE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT THAT
MEANS.
UNFORTUNATELY NOBODY ASKED.
IN THE COMING WEEKS WE ARE GOING
TO DO OUR BEST TO FIND OUT.
IT IS OUR GOVERNMENT POLICY IN
MATTERS AND WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND
OUT.
IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE PUNISHMENT.